and if we talk about Natasha it always
brings a smile to our face and it's
because she was wonderful Natasha
abrahart took her own life during her
second year at Bristol University
struggling with social anxiety her
well-being deteriorated as she faced
increasing pressure around a group
presentation her Department was made
aware of her situation
Natasha's flatmate actually approached
the department telling them Natasha's
having suicidal thoughts and some
attempt so some degree attempted it at
that point you think people would pick
up on it and do something
in fact yes they helped her to get to
the GP service but did nothing else in
the department
ultimately a court found the
University's failures contributed to
Natasha's death at the time Bristol said
staff worked hard and diligently to
support her and that it's committed to
providing the best possible support for
students
the case sparked conversation around
student mental health today the
government's committed to investing more
into Provisions offered at University
students space the well-being platform
will be funded for at least the next
three years and three million pounds has
already been allocated to Bridging the
Gap between universities and NHS
Services some universities I've seen and
heard about are great they're very proud
proactive in terms of the support they
offer other universities are incredibly
unproactive and I think actually we need
so much more regulation and guidance
from the government and there's also
concern around how well-trained
University staff are Sky News obtained
data from 109 universities it showed
that 98 offer student-facing staff
Mental Health Training however it isn't
mandatory in 63 percent of these
institutions and while 37 have some form
of mandate in most cases this doesn't
cover All-Star off it should be part of
the duty of care that all University
staff and that includes cleaning staff
as well as lecturing staff should have
towards their students it should be
inherent in what the universities do
four years on Natasha's parents continue
campaigning even with more investments
into student mental health changes won't
happen overnight they just hope others
don't go through what she did Aisha
zahid Sky News